here don't shove them back
reconcile this energy here
body tilt
and i'm not throwing her with my arm
my arm is aiming her so it's just
staying up
work on that part please
oh
so
that's that adhesion okay got it
you're not getting out of the way and
they come flying in and then you
accelerate them backwards
okay
luke is pulling
i can be on the outside
you don't need the head
right
[Applause]
there's
you're fine
i go slow say that
you can tell that
you're pulling
you see but if you're just doing it
[Music]
no one can tell that he's pulling do you
see that
so
that was you pulley
okay
so you gotta figure out
because it's not
me pulling you
hey
okay we'll go back to the spinal
displacement that he's trying to do okay
um so not not pulling anyone but
pulling and pushing is not
it's a false dichotomy okay
um
when you can internalize things all
right
so um
let us pay attention to
the yin yang cycles of the tesla okay
so what's going to happen is the arm is
going to pass from a yin phase
into a two hand
transition
and as that hand
exits its face the other hand enters its
face until
it enters into a new two-hand transition
and then they cycle through okay
so uh as it's coming through
there is a there's a moment here where
both hands are on on both hands i'll
exaggerate the length of the trend but
both hands are in your body right now
cassie so both hands are kind of doing
that okay
what i tend to see you do is you go you
go one hand and dead
and then is dead and then the other hand
comes okay
that's going to make it very difficult
to get in someone's body with the
internal aspects okay because you you're
turning the floor on and off
so
on
it's starting to go off when it starts
to go off the other hand will be on with
it on
until this goes off you see and this
hand is on and now guess what
here's the other half and you'll see if
this hand keeps going eventually it goes
off
so
we're back a little
the two hands together are going when
you feel that hand go off this hand
becomes dominant now do you see
and it's the one that's bringing him
back you guys keep doing this hand and
this is off this hand will not go off
till about here where it's just
falling with him and that's where the
throwing hand becomes the dominant hand
so
phasing
together facing out together
phased out
so on that note
because you do this on off stuff
it really doesn't matter what to you
where you're putting this hat
you change it all the time
you grab
you grab you do
you're going to find this the best place
to be
okay
so i got some jaw
and some neck
some mastoid
and some
throat can you see
okay
so home
together
now look together
knowledge together
facing out
and you don't need to pull them back
because you're not accelerating
something backwards so you shouldn't
hold the key
that's for somebody who does not have
the internal aspects okay
i'm stuck
get that hand in the right place okay